We'll rip her out root and stem.
The objective here is to remove Cersei
without destroying King's Landing
Hey everyone it's Charlie this is going to be
my Game of Thrones season 8 episode 4
video so here we go the gullet has been
thrown so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Game of Thrones videos there's also
a bunch of separate prequel game of
Thrones stuff that happened recently
that I'll do a separate video for
sometime next week too this is a new
round of the HBO now giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video and
obviously spoiler warning for episode 4
if you have not seen the episode yet top
15 in Easter eggs there was a lot of
foreshadowing as well as callbacks to
previous episodes because they're trying
to close things down in the next couple
of episodes we have the last war in next
week's episode and then whatever the
finale is going to be they're also
trying to foreshadow a lot of
pregnancies children things happening
the last couple of episodes so don't be
surprised for a couple big twists number
15 though the funeral they opened the
episode with a really somber soundtrack
as you pan up sword roars body Daenerys
is mourning him she whispered something
in his ear that we can't quite hear I
just assumed that it was something sweet
about how much he meant to her this
whole time even though she didn't love
him romantically the way that he wanted
to Sansa does the same thing to Theon
she even gives him a stark sigil pin
sort of naming him your stark of
Winterfell you're one of us even if
you're not biologically related to us if
you don't remember - I've used this
picture a couple times this is of the
stark children and Theon before they
started filming season 1 this was at a
book signing that they went to for
George our Martin before they started
production on the show so remember Leon
is actually an OG start child even
though technically he's not a stark the
speech that Jon Snow gave as they
started to burn the bodies is also a
callback to the Nights Watch both we are
the shields to protect the realms of men
he says they were the shield that
protected the realms of men they're like
we'll never be seen again
so the referencing a lot of Nights Watch
customs but also a lot of northern
customs because a lot of these people
that died were northerners including Sir
Jorah of Bear Island or IP a little bear
r.i.p Mormont's - there was this whole
thing going through the episode about
them wanting to separate Daenerys and
make her feel more isolated as she
starts to lose more and more of her
support system loser children aka
the dragons as well as it seems the
allegiance of her inner circle talking
about beerus we'll get to all that stuff
you kind of see them visually foreshadow
that too as you see Daenerys standing
way way apart from Jon Snow in the
stark children like you have them way
over on one side you have Daenerys way
over on the other side number fourteen
the great feast obviously much more
somber than the last great feast that we
saw in here back during season one when
Robert Baratheon arrived but things pick
up eventually one of my favorite
characters during all these banquet
scenes as much fun as people were having
there were a lot of funny character
moments who was the Hound who was sort
of being bah humbug about everything
like he just could not stand everybody
celebrating so much just because he's
still so focused on his brother the
mountain and cleganebowl feel kind of
bad for that northern girl that he
passed off but number 13 they pay off a
big fan theory that's been going on for
the last couple of seasons
Daenerys legitimizes Gendry as Gendry
Baratheon in names him Lord of storms
end I feel like the line of dialogue
where they say does anyone know who the
current Lord of storms end is and no one
can answer is actually a meta joke in
real life because the fandom has been
asking that question for the last couple
of seasons I've seen it on many many of
my episode videos going back to season
four five six like who's the Lord of
storms and now that both Stannis and
Renly are gone is it Gendry wouldn't it
to legitimize him and that's where all
the Gendry being legitimized theory
started is it well if he's legitimized
then he can become Lord of storms in and
that'll saw up that plot hole there's
also kind of a funny line of dialogue
from Davos talking about the Lord of
Light like he just totally screwed off
after Melisandre took off and they
defeated the White Walkers like what
does the Lord of Light want with us now
if he was so big on this war for the
dawn we want it then he just completely
takes off we could talk forever about
the importance of the mythological
elements of the show in the narrative as
well as the human elements but obviously
the last couple of episodes mostly seem
like they're going to focus on people
versus people like they're trying to say
that is terrible is the night king in
the White Walkers were the things that
people will do to each other are way
worse but number 12 I didn't love that
moment between bran stark and Tyrion
they're talking more about the
succession everybody's talking about
succession because of Jon Snow the Iron
Throne Rhaegar Targaryen Leon a stark
but Tyrion raises the question aren't
you going to be a Lord of Winterfell and
bran has to explain no I can't do that
I'm not a person I can't have any male
heirs and I don't want any
anymore I mostly live in the past I
think they did this just to remind you
that brand still has all of his
abilities he hasn't stopped being the
three eye Raven and his abilities will
continue to be important for the next
couple of episodes but it's also a
reference to the title of the episode
aka the last star because right now
technically Brandt is the last
natural-born star hundred percent stark
because Jon Snow is only 50% stark but
it also foreshadows more Jon Snow
Daenerys baby in the future too because
their baby would be another part Stark
only 25 percent stark but still brain
stark would no longer be the last stark
I really love it when he references a
lot of historical stuff in Song of Ice
and Fire it's always funny to hear
name-drop stuff like that I had this
wheelchair built to spec based on Darren
Targaryens it was my favorite he built
it for his crippled nephew more than a
hundred years ago also funny moment Yan
Royce shows back up for those of you
that wondered where he was during
episode three because he did not appear
apparently in that episode even though
he should have been hiding down in the
crypts with everyone else number eleven
they sort of start the Daenerys slide to
freakout mode
Daenerys starts to go a little bit nuts
when torment won't stop boasting about
Jon being an amazing king that everyone
loves they all toast him everyone's
getting drunk all over the place but
they're really trying to lay it on thick
that everyone loves Jon Snow and remind
you that he's still king in the north
but the word king means something very
different to Daenerys because she knows
the truth probably the biggest surprise
is part of this denier storyline this
week was Varys I was not expecting him
to turn on her so quickly but I'll talk
about that in a second number 10 all the
Brienne Jaime drinking contest and fan
service pay off they finally get
together I wasn't actually expecting
this I'm happy they did it I liked them
together as a couple I feel like the
show has developed their relationship
more than it has for any other pair on
the show like Jon Snow and Daenerys are
supposed to have this epic relationship
that's full of all this drama now
because of all the information they've
revealed but the show has spent so much
more time in so many more seasons
developing Jaime and Brienne as a couple
together but obviously he's a tragic
character so the way he leaves goes back
to King's Landing to join the war it
pretty much seems like Brandon
understands that he's not going to come
back and I think that Jaime is on all of
our death predictions list this season
but there was a nice callback when they
were finally together and she sort of
helps him under
it was a nice callback to the season 3
episode when she helped him eat his food
almost as if they were an old married
couple already at this point number 9
was the Sansa hound reunion I really
loved their moment together they haven't
had a real reunion since the season
started everyone kept asking what about
Sansa and the Hound going all the way
back to sweet little bird back in the
early seasons whatever you think about
the writing in the storylines in the
other episodes I feel like a lot of this
dialogue here works really well if I had
gone with you like you'd wanted I would
still be a little bird today and I loved
that funny reaction from the Hound when
he finds out that Sansa fed Ramsay to
his hounds it pretty much seems like the
way the Hound went out in the episode
with Arya that he's going back for
cleganebowl does not plan on coming back
so he expects to die during the attempt
but Arya is also going back to cross
Circe's name off of her list they drop a
really big reference to the end of
season 4 where he says are you going to
leave me to die again and she says yes
I'm probably going to leave you to die
pretty seriously but also kind of joking
a little bit making it sound like when
the Hound eventually engages in real
cleganebowl Arya may help out in the
Hound we'll probably pretty definitely
die from his wounds it's the last couple
of episodes so of course the body count
is going to go up more and more next week's
episode is just an even bigger excuse
for that because you have an actual real
big war being fought number eight Gendry
proposes marriage to arya and not
surprisingly she says That's not me she
gives in the exact same speech
referencing season one with Ned Stark
then again at the beginning of season
seven when she had the reunion with
Nymeria oh that's not you even if you're
really bummed that it seems like they
might not wind out together I do feel
like the show is sticking to its earlier
logic like they are trying to pay off
that arc like Arya Stark is not a lady
that's going to live in a castle someday so
the only way that they would be together
is if Kendra didn't want to be the lord
of storms end and I'm sure there's going to
be a lot of questions about whether or
not Arya is now pregnant with Kendra's
child because it seems like all the
women on the show are getting pregnant
these last couple of episodes seven was
Daenerys demanding begging Jon Snow to
be silent about his secret I know
they're going to be a lot of people to be
really upset about this part of the
storyline and of all the storylines
during the episode this did feel like
the biggest left turn like why is
Daenerys suddenly acting so crazy just
the look on Emilia Clarke's face when
she's performing this scene
it's almost like she's in terror of
what's going to happen that she wouldn't
win the Iron Throne because everybody's
going to love Jon Snow so much more even
though Jon Snow is trying to do
everything he can to talk sense into her
and calm her down we'll talk about this
the next couple of episodes too because
obviously there's only a couple episodes
left so they're going to have to bring this
to a head pretty fast but everyone seems
to think the biggest hang-up in all this
because why wouldn't you just get the
married that would solve all our
problems is because they think that Jon
Snow won't marry her because they're
related but they're not really counting
on any potential pregnancy which I think
would seal the deal for them like that
would definitely make Jon Snow want to
marry Daenerys on the spot he absolutely
hates the idea of bastards because of
the way he grew up being shunned by what
seems like Catelyn Stark just treating
him terribly so if he were to find that
he had a child with Daenerys
and they weren't married that baby would
be a bastard he would hate that idea so
it sure would solve a lot of their
problems if Daenerys were to lay a new
dragon eggs sometime soon or at least
find out that she's pregnant I also kind
of think that they're going to parallel
that pregnant Daenerys storyline with
Cersei being pregnant storyline they
kept talking about children and
pregnancies the last 15 minutes of the
episode including Samwell and Gilly who
look like they're either going to have a
baby Jon or who knows what they're
going to name it if it's a girl
I'm sure there'll be a lot of questions
about what Samwell is going to do now -
because it seems like they're not going to
participate in the war to come so maybe
they just go back to horn Hill and he
becomes Lord of horn Hill 6 was all the
battle planning although it seems like a
lot of that went out the window by the
end of the episode
most of the early plan is just a wait
Cersei out give her time to sort of eat
herself alive so to speak like she's a
terrible person her people hate her
Cersei hates her people as Tyrion says
at the end of the episode if they
starved the city out using a blockade
long enough then the people will just
kick Cersei to the curb but because
they're hyping up all this drama between
the groups Daenerys demands Jon Snow
obey and he's trying to do everything he
can to do that he even steps over Sansa
who wants to wait a little while to give
the troops time to rest which obviously
number 5 billed to Jon revealing the
truth to Sansa and Arya I love the way
they cut away - they don't give you
their direct reaction you only see it on
sonses face later when she's looking at
the dragon's fly over Winterfell just
deep in thought like what are we going to
do about this I'm glad that they didn't
draw this out even though all the
backstabbing and the intrigue and the
double deal
in betrayals that are going on within
Denise's camp seem kind of odd at this
point but number four welcome back bran
so we finally pick up with the bronze
storyline who just waltzes in with the
crossbow
they both immediately notice the
crossbow they definitely remember that
it's the one that was used to kill Tywin
it seemed like it took him a couple
minutes to catch up with what was
happening in the moment they just
thought that he was showing up like what
are you doing here with that crossbow
that looks like the crossbow that I used
to kill my father with but we get the
details of Circe's terms he'll be Lord
of Riverrun for killing Jaime and Tyrion
and they double his price by offering
him Highgarden there's actually an
easter egg for the beginning of the
Lannister family if you don't remember
land the clever is the person that
started the Lannister family when Jaime
tries to shade him a little bit he says
your ancestors were no better than me
he's actually not wrong because
supposedly land the clever the person
that started House Lannister conned the
former owners of Casterly Rock house
Cass truly out of the castle so very
literally the Lannisters conned their
way into the nobility of Westeros
thousands and thousands of years ago we
might actually see that play out on one
of the prequel TV series three everybody
launches a plot against Daenerys Sansa
seems like she's plotting against
Daenerys what if Tyrion what if there
were someone better than Daenerys so
clearly she's told him because of the
conversation that he has with beerus on
the boat later but whatever her ideas
are it also seems like now Varys is
launching a plot against Daenerys and
based on the final conversation he had
with Tyrion after the little war council
it sounds like he's willing to quote
unquote get rid of Daenerys if she
becomes a problem so we're in full on
treason mode now and Daenerys looks like
she's going to burn anything that steps in
her way so I would not be surprised if
she winds up executing Varys at some
point in the next episode or two Tyrion
kind of half-heartedly seems like he
wants to believe Daenerys will do the
right thing given the right advice from
her inner circle so it seems like he
still wants to be team Daenerys even
though looking past his comments he
clearly says that he thinks that Jon
Snow would be a better ruler than
Daenerys and they're both worried that
Jon doesn't want to have anything to do
with the marriage with her because
they're related but he's not completely
ready to give up on Daenerys so just
remember that they're trying to prevent
Daenerys from burning King's Landing to
the ground with the dragon would not be
surprised if they try to bring back some
wildfire twist in King's Landing
does wind up burning to the ground there
were just too many times during the
episode where Tyrion referenced fire
burning King's Landing want to hear all
the screams even Qyburn is like no I
don't want to hear those screams that
would sound terrible but they haven't
referenced wildfire in a while so I
wouldn't be surprised if they try to
roll out some twists in the next episode
or two and because we're getting a lot
of goodbyes during the episode you get
torment saying to Jon that he's taking
the wildlings back to Castle black we
just need room to roam maybe they'll
just colonize the new gift like they did
during the books or they're also go back
north of the wall because at least in
the short term it seems like the threat
of the knight king of the White Walkers
is gone even though I know a lot of you
are like hey wait a minute
are they going to bring them back at the
end of the show is the night king
completely dead or will he make a
surprise reappearance it just seems like
for now the wildlings are saying that
they're going to go back north for good and
Jon says will you please take ghost
with you he needs room to roam too so
why no a lot of you are really upset
about what they'd done was ghost the
past couple of seasons you can see he
lost one of his ears during the battle
and they kind of tried to have a goodbye
moment with Jon where they kind of look
at each other and remember because the
direwolves have like a low-level psychic
connection with the stark children that
they belong to they say goodbye to each
other but it's unspoken you get a little
whimper from ghost and Jon looks really
sad about it number two huge you're
on killing grey go with the scorpions so
I know a lot of people are questioning
the logic of how this all went down
because they hit Rago with three
successive shots perfectly placed
they're able to tear all their ships to
shreds but they're unable to even get
close to hitting Daenerys maybe they're
true shot and champion trolled off but I
know a lot of you are wondering if the
dragons are going to be able to lay more
eggs that would only work if drogon had
actually flipped genders and was
actually the one to lay the eggs now
because it seems like Ragle is dead but
it is possible for dragons within the
world of A Song of Ice and Fire to sort
of flip gender so even if drogon and
Ragle were male originally drogon could
flip genders become a female and they
could become a mated pair number one
of course was Cersei executing Miss and
I in throwing the gauntlet for Daenerys
for next week's big battle the last war
she calls it Jon Snow is also marching
south with the troops from Winterfell
the ones that are left just remember all
the things that Tyrion said when he was
trying to appeal to Qyburn and then to
Cersei so one he keeps referencing
Cersei's unborn child talking about
children women being pregnant having
babies just a parallel I think for
what's going to happen with Daenerys'
storyline but also referencing burning
the city down which reminds you of the
Mad King so obviously they want you to
think about Daenerys the way you thought
about the Mad King because of what Varys
said I've served many tyrants they all
talk about destiny so let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from the episode what do you think about
the idea of Daenerys potentially getting
pregnant in someone burning King's
Landing to the ground what'll happen is
I'll post my Game of Thrones episode
5 trailer video tomorrow there's also
supposed to be a Spider Man far from
home trailer in the morning so that'll
probably be my next video then I'll post
the Game of Thrones trailer while you
wait for everything click here for my
episode 3 video and click here for my
episode 2 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!